Filmmaking is a disease,
and you have to be sick.
And I'm super sick.
[LAUGHING]
[NON-ENGLISH MUSIC]
The first thing that I would
tell an aspiring filmmaker
is to educate yourself.
Be permeable to what is
around you with humility,
with respect, and
with also, an ability
to see yourself in that world
so that that world trusts you.
That's key.
I want to do this MasterClass
to demystify the process.
Welcome to the workshop
of the "Queen of Katwe."
We are doing one scene to
show how to direct actors.
Actors look for the
ability to trust.
Your work as a director
is to create a space where
they are allowed to bloom.
When I'm budgeting
the picture, I'm
not going to let
people see my struggle.
My formula is that every scene
has to do more than one thing.
Every scene has to
do three things.
Films under the guise
of entertainment
should open windows
in your heart.
Nothing is more
powerful than seeing
your own language, your
own color, your own people,
your own dramas on screen.
If you don't tell your own
story, no one else will.
I'm Mira Nair, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]